sos mundial para detener la
contaminación plástica en Solo dos
décadas la producción mundial de
plástico se ha duplicado hasta alcanzar
las 460 millones de toneladas según el
informe de perspectiva mundial de los
plásticos de la ocde para el año 2060 se
prevé que esta cifra se triplique las
negociaciones de París para prohibir
plásticos altamente contaminantes son
complejas y hay tropiezos pero también
anuncios esperanzadores
la buena noticia es que ningún país se
ha opuesto a que se diga que algunos
plásticos son más peligrosos para el
medio ambiente que otros se puede
establecer el principio de prohibición
de algunos de estos plásticos Incluso en
los países productores detrás de la
contaminación plástica hay una próspera
industria instalada en países
productores cuyos gobiernos aún ponen
resistencia a las prohibiciones
estamos tratando de continuar gracias a
los equipos negociadores empujando las
negociaciones para lograr convencer y
mover las posiciones de todos
especialmente a los países productores
organizaciones ecologistas advierten
poca voluntad de países petroleros
por supuesto hay países que han sido
influenciados por la industria de los
combustibles fósiles como Arabia Saudita
es uno de los que hemos visto que han
estado retrocediendo
la contaminación por plásticos aumenta a
medida que crecen las economías está
previsto que la siguiente Ronda de
negociaciones sobre la prohibición se
realice en noviembre próximo en Kenia